true story the tiger population in Asia  the tiger population has increased 30  percent in the last four years and I  think yeah that's amazing  I was thrilled by this isn't that great  news Andy no it's not I'm sorry what  what are you talking about Tigers Tigers  are endangered look I'm glad the tiger  population is up but that's just because  they're mating more often and with a  greater potency due to a controversial  new aphrodisiac made of powdered human  penises powdered human penises take a  look at this you'll see what I'm talking  about  powdered human penis is popular in the  black market and is widely believed to  heighten sexual arousal and older Tigers  each year humans are illegally shot by  Tiger poachers who then harvest their  penises  and then snort them the result is more  tiger but it works  [Music]  Andy are you sure about any of this  no Conan I'm not  you